1 million eight hundred and seventy
thousand tests to date and now we're
performing them at a level that nobody's
ever seen before
cBS testing sites in Georgia and Rhode
Island will be using Abbott Labs rapid
five-minute tests that means a lot of
very fast tests no nation in the world
has developed a more diverse and robust
testing capacity than the United States
President Trump highlighting the
expansion of the coronavirus testing
throughout the country here with more
its assistant secretary for Health and
Human Services and a member of the White
House coronavirus Task Force four-star
Admiral brett sure wha
Admiral good morning to you good morning
to you thanks for having me it's great
to have you because you're giving
America updates on the very latest it's
interesting we were listening to dr.
Burks and the president last night talk
from the podium in the briefing room
about these Abbott machines and she had
an appeal that if you've got one let's
let's try to figure out how your area
can use it could you just explain what
she's talking about and what these
Abbott machines can do so
Abbott makes a whole variety of machines
the rapid five-minute point-of-care
tests that you alluded to what
ambassador birx was talking about is a
relatively high throughput machine that
abbott makes that we know a lot of
hospitals have and we're able to track
exactly how many tests they're doing in
order to maximize the capacity the
country we want those machines to be in
full use so we're really going to an
individual individual kind of hospital
work right now to make sure that every
possible test that can be run will be
run
dr. Brooks was talking yesterday about
these antibody tests and I hadn't even
thought of this until she mentioned it
but she said there's some companies out
there that are trying to sell antibody
tests online she warns people
well here's her warning listen to this
if you see them on the internet do not
buy them some of the tests that may be
available on the Internet may have very
low sensitivity and specificity and give
you a fuss
that you either give you a false
positive or a false negative implying
that you may be protected what's your
message for the folks that are watching
there there isn't there hasn't been one
that's been approved right or it's not
available so I want to distinguish for
all your viewers up until now all the
tests we've been speaking about
diagnosed do you have the virus in your
nose are you actively shedding are you
infected the antibody test would be able
to tell you have you been infected in
the past so it detects an immune
response to the virus meaning that
you're likely not ever going to be able
to get it again or at least in the in
the short term of many years that's the
test right now that are coming on to the
market most of them almost all of them
have not been through FDA authorization
and we are very concerned that many of
the tests are really just not accurate
so in the government right now the FDA
CDC NIH are trying to validate all the
tests that are out there that we know
about to make sure they really perform
we've heard international stories of
governments and you might have seen it a
couple days ago the United Kingdom
bought almost 20 million tests and they
just don't work at all there they don't
perform well so there's no need to have
this test right now we are developing
the methods we have the methods and
we're validating which tests are good
and as soon as we do that you'll be
hearing from us very shortly probably in
the next week to give the public
assurance of which ones really work and
don't and there'll be a really national
testing plan around these antibody tests
as well so Admiral a couple of days ago
famously you took a question from the
podium and they said that Inspector
General did a report and it turns out
three surveys of 300-plus hospitals show
the prevailing thought was there wasn't
enough gloves it was enough shields
there was enough masks you said well if
that won't that's not the case but it
was true I wish that person would have
told me rather than run to the press how
many hospitals do you think are short of
any of these things well it's it's we
get source to every single day we have
regional administrators from FEMA
we have HHS regional administrators we
talk to most of the major hospital
systems directly and particularly in the
hotspot areas and up
now particularly with gowns gloves and
95 masks
we've been able to fill all the needs
that we've been told about at first we
started at the regional level and now
we're going down to individual hospitals
that's Admiral plug check saying that so
I know there's a lot of concern in the
community I'm an intensive care doctor
and if you're worried about not having
the right masks or for example if the
master sitting in a warehouse down the
street they've been delivered by the
federal government but haven't gotten to
your hospital that is a concern that's
why we've even moved to the next step
here at FEMA and HHS by supplying
hospitals specifically going door to
door if that Hospital has a need and
they're not getting met that we really
do that so so that's really the posture
we're in right now right now yes okay
but ultimately Admiral that's after
somebody becomes infected and they need
hospitalization and that's when they
wind up on one of the beds or one of the
ICU beds as well right now what's very
encouraging is the fact that when you
look at the social distancing that for
the most part the entire country is
doing and we should point out that the
CDC director said a couple of days ago
said yesterday that apparently you know
those super dire predictions that maybe
a quarter of a million Americans could
die that was awful but at the same time
now they're saying it probably won't be
that bad because those estimates were
based on only half the country doing
social distancing right now it seems
like everybody's in this for the folks
watching right now they got to know that
what they're doing staying away from
people is actually working and it will
save lives there there is no doubt that
the physical distancing and all the
precautions that we've said every day
that the president and the vice
president said ambassador birx they work
on they really do work and that's how
you stop this virus right now until we
have vaccines and medications and all
the other things social distancing I
prefer to call it physical distancing I
want you to still be social with your
your friends over Facebook but physical
distancing is incredibly important and
remember the projections I've seen
people twist that like this was not
going to be that bad after
and we didn't need to do that that's a
complete misinterpretation the estimates
of deaths going down is a result of the
fact that we've listened to the
President and the Vice President in the
task force if we did nothing the deaths
could have been two million three
million people in the United States
using moderate impact social distancing
it could have been a couple hundred
thousand now we know that the American
public is doing a fantastic job in doing
that physical distancing and now the
estimates probably are under a hundred
thousand that's still a horrible amount
of deaths but it's much less than it
could have been but I do want to
emphasize the point there is a light at
the end of the tunnel but don't keep
your foot don't take your foot off the
gas because we really need to continue
these efforts because we could see
another peak a second peak a third peak
if people don't do the physical
distancing or they think it's all over
it's not over yet listen to what we what
we explain on the podium and also your
state and local public health
department's good advice Admiral thank
you for your work you're welcome
have a good one thank you